let's play e6 king e7 i think i can
afford to play the bomb cloud
king is heaven and back
okay let's put the knight here
i'ma play d5 because i need to fight for
space
[Music]
okay so if white plays e5 then we get a
close position
we're making is relatively safe in the
center
and the most important thing for me
right now is to keep making safe
so i'm provoking him to play e5
after which we'll see what happens i'll
play bishop d7
protecting my then i'll take this
and i'll play f6 try to get some counter
play in the center
i mean obviously white is for choice but
i think it's not
very clear at this point
what's happening so i'll take
take
se5 fe-5 snow white can either take with
the knight or with the pawn
uh i think white is better because of
the
the bishop pair
but it's not uh not a big deal of the
moment so i'll bring my queen here
then knight d7 next
97 my favorite chess player from history
my favorite chess player is anatoly
karpov
so what there are a lot of great chess
players out there
like bishi and gary kasparov bobby
fischer
but i'm always i've always loved anatoly
karpov's way of playing chess
because it's not forceful he's just very
strategic
it's not really about killing the
opponent in preparation it's just
slow strategic play improving your
position step by step
and
trying to seize the opportunities that
your opponent gives you
so in that regard he's the best rook
effect
mashups you want to play danish
danish gambit sure
queen takes a b6
let's see i'm play bishop b7 then play
c5 next
no i've never played against carpool
i mean i met him in person a few times
but never got the honor to play him
but back in the 80s 70s and 90s
carpool was a tremendous player
oh okay bishop e3
so uh uh
yeah white blunder the peace
rook d8
i'm only reading the chess 24 chat
king is seven uh
[Music]
so this
is one of my few successes with the bomb
cloud
i think i might i can go c4 and then
take on f4
arca volume will you play your e4
chessable lines
yeah i will it's just i played it
tens of times already it gets boring
after a while
okay they should be winning
car pops games are so boring yeah
uh i think if you look at the